as a kid growing up here in wisconsin in
the 1970s
i got exposed to soccer pretty early on
in my elementary school time when i was
around six years old and
that was rather unusual for that era
maybe not so much in a few parts of the
united states but it was definitely
you know a different thing
than what had been going on in the
midwest
up until that time
and the way that i wound up playing
soccer and becoming you know really
into the sport and getting quite good at
it was through chance
my dad had wanted to sign me up for
little league we lived in what was
called the township of delafield there's
mostly empty country space you know
prairies and woods and things like that
and then the rather underdeveloped
subdivision that we lived in
all of which had been farmers fields at
one time and then there was the town of
delafield
which was about i don't know maybe
four or five miles away probably four
miles away from where we lived and then
there was the village of wales which was
less than a mile from where we lived so
we lived on the border of delafield in
wales and in the town hall
of delafield you could sign your kids up
for sports for the summer like you know
to keep them busy and
i think moms liked it because they would
drop us off in the morning and then we
were out of their hair until the
afternoon and they had some alone time
without kids well we sweated in the sun
and did whatever we were going to do
so my dad takes me in there
and i actually remember this you know i
i have some vague
episodic memory of this we go to
sign me up and there's like this long
list right and
somebody asked like well how old is this
kid and my dad said um you know you tell
them and i said i'm six and they said
well you can't play little league you
have to be seven to play little league
now i am a august birthday right so
i was always younger than the rest of
the kids in my my class because the
cutoff was you had to be a certain age
before school started school started
just after my birthday
and so
i was just old enough to get into first
grade and second grade but during the
summer i was still
at that young age whereas most of my
classmates after first grade were you
know already seven i was only six
so my dad said well what do you mean he
can't play well you know they gave him
some some sort of run around and so then
my dad didn't want to waste time
and having made that drive and so he was
like well what can he play
and they said well there's there's
soccer over there you could you could
sign him up for that
and that's what we did
so
starting in june
after school let out
my mom would drop me off in the morning
with a bag lunch
and uh like a thermos of of of water
and
um you know i wore a white t-shirt
because they told us all wear either
white red green or blue t-shirts those
are the teams that you're gonna be on
and i had a you know undershirt like so
many of the other kids so she dropped me
off there and you know they lined us all
up and they're like okay you know we got
a lot of people wearing white shirts not
as many wearing the others we're going
to start doing some drills and teaching
you about soccer don't use your hands
unless you're the goalie and all this
sort of stuff and you know we learn how
to like bonk it with our heads and do
chest traps and how to how to you know
kick back and forth with you know how to
dribble right and it was a lot of fun
right and it turns out i was pretty good
at that sort of stuff and i wasn't that
good at other sports
which were more typically american right
we back at that time there were there
were really four main sports and we
didn't we didn't have too much chance to
play hockey right because you need
equipment for that but you know there
was baseball and then there was football
and then there was basketball and each
had their season and you'd play him you
know a bit in gym class or out in the
yard with other kids and everybody had a
glove you know just about everybody had
a bat and so we played a lot of games
like that in the neighborhood
and you know if you look at my glasses
that i wear you notice that the right
lens is a lot thicker than the left lens
that's because
even back then
this eye is is always been
you know problematic it's got an
astigmatism that's really quite strong
my left eye is pretty good
and so um
i didn't know that i needed glasses at
the time i just knew i had terrible
depth perception so that made baseball
kind of kind of difficult every time i
was like putting my hand out to catch a
ball i wasn't quite sure if it was going
to get there or not shooting baskets
could be difficult as well whereas doing
layups super easy for me right
and football you know catching passes
not so easy running with the ball
tackling people that that i could do i
was i was a skinny kid really skinny kid
but i was you know i was pretty scrappy
and tall and
as it turned out
soccer had everything i i wanted to do
so they split us up for scrimmages into
everybody wearing in the white shirts
and then everybody wearing the other
shirts we probably had like 30 people on
each side and i was one of the youngest
kids in the mix
and they're like well just try not to
get hurt and put me in the back you know
to be a fullback what a lot of people
call a defender
and you know the ball starts coming with
the other team coming down the field
and as it turned out i was pretty good
even though i was like one of the the
youngest kids at taking the ball away
from these other guys who are trying to
score a goal on us and i could kick the
ball pretty far up the field so some of
the older kids were like
well let this kid play you know here
comes the uh the four words go to it
little greg go take the ball away from
them and i loved it you know i loved
that that like older kids were treating
me as if i was part of the team i loved
being able to do it i enjoyed the sheer
physicality of it you know before long i
was learning how to like slide tackle
and stuff stuff like that and
i became a pretty good defender
over that summer and over the next
summer and then we would sometimes you
know play soccer in the yard as well
now
when i got to third grade
something really cool happened
the local uh
they started organizing all these local
soccer teams for for us kids
and wales was you know so close and i
actually went to wales elementary so i
became a whale's dragon you know because
the town was welsh that's why it was
called whales
and we had like a dragon you know on our
on our shirt you know our jersey
and we started playing all these other
teams you know we'd have to travel to to
go to heartland or oconomowoc or
delafield or mukwonaco or we could go
down the list i think there were like
eight teams in our league and you'd have
like a roster and we were pretty good we
were actually a pretty strong team
um we played with um
it's kind of interesting to think about
this
our formation was five guys up in the
front as forwards
right and then we had three half backs
and then there was two of us defenders
and then the goalie and our goalie was a
guy who had only one and a half arms it
was his one arm was cut off at the elbow
some of the kids used to make fun of him
on the other teams not on our team
and then he would show them just how
good he was and they wouldn't score on
on this guy
and he could throw pretty far with that
as well now me
and the other guy
as i mentioned i was pretty tall and i
was pretty aggressive
you know by then i had like soccer
cleats and stuff like that i was very
skinny but i but i was um you know fast
and i also had another advantage i would
play on the left while this other guy
who is bigger than me a little bit you
know slower uh but very powerful played
on the right as the defenders
so i'm
at that i'm not fully ambidextrous
anymore but at that time i was
ambidextrous i could play equally well
with my right as i could with my left
and vice versa i could do things with my
hands more or less equally you know they
back then they didn't like you doing
left-handed stuff so they made me right
with my my right hand but soccer i could
do just as much with my left including
kicking and trapping and all the other
things that go along with it so i would
play on the left with the weak side and
then he would play on the right the
strong side and between the two of us
and this goalie
three guys on defense we would stop
people short you know and it was a lot
of fun i really enjoyed it
my dad started getting into it because
my sister my youngest sister who was
three grades behind me she started
playing as well
for like a junior team and then he
coached that team and he had books about
soccer so i'd i'd read his books and
stuff and now notice we didn't we never
got to see soccer like on tv or anything
like that we that just wasn't on our
radar it was just a game that we we
played and it was it was fun and cool
then
uh
you know some of people have heard me
talk about this before i went to a
school university lake school
where
um you know is it like a college prep
from six to
grade 12
private
expensive i got in on scholarship my
parents did that in part because the
regular school system wanted to kick me
up a grade and
kettle moraine was not very good at that
time so
they found a way for me to get in
along with a couple other kids on
scholarship i think we were basically
there to keep the test scores up because
you were either really smart or you were
really rich and there wasn't a lot of
overlap in that place
one thing that was really distinctive
about uls was that they took soccer
seriously
so seriously that the gym teacher and
soccer coach was a former olympian
former uh us team player right
mr heffernan and
soccer was what we did
basically when we got to school
uh you know for gym class every gym
class for the entire fall
until it got too cold to be outside was
soccer and the girls were playing field
hockey that was their their shtick as
well you know nobody had a choice about
it
you were on the soccer team whether you
liked it or not and i i loved it i
thought this is so awesome we also would
play soccer during our lunch periods
we'd scarf our food down and then go
into the gym
and play indoor soccer during the winter
we'd play outside when we weren't doing
things like running around in the woods
and getting sticks and trying to hit
each other and calling it knights or
other things along those lines playing
tag
so soccer was a big deal at university
lake school so big
that they didn't have a football team
for their high school because they only
had like you know
20 people in a class
i think you know and they would play
another school a public school arrowhead
in heartland which had at least 10 times
as many people to draw on for playing
soccer and there was this this trophy
ball that was
on one side every year would be
repainted it was green and white on one
side red and white on the other because
green and white was uls and red and
white was arrowhead and whichever side
one got to paint in the other parts of
the ball
and uls would win more often i think
than arrowhead did so that's what the
bigger kids were doing
so you know i i played a lot of soccer i
really enjoyed it we'd play it in our
neighborhood as well and
then that kind of you know that ended a
bit playing on teams once i got to high
school that was more of a factor of
you know our household being
disorganized because i could have played
when when i went to catholic memorial i
could have been on the soccer team but
my mom
uh didn't you know sign me up for it and
i didn't know because nobody told me
that i had to like show up to practices
before the school year started i kind of
assumed i could just like get on the
soccer team and then found out nope
tryouts were back in july and you know
so things were kind of a mess and
instead i would play soccer with you
know again the kids in the neighborhood
or we would play it in gym class every
spring
we would spend weeks playing soccer and
then i was like holy crap this is a
great time you know i mean
indoor hockey was fun too i like that
and track and field but playing soccer
was something that i i just love to do
and so you know once again i would
usually play fullback sometimes uh
and just go at it you know and and not
all the kids were quite as athletic
so you know it was pretty easy to blow
past them
i did actually break somebody's ankle
uh
my junior year i think it was we were
both going for the ball at exactly the
same time we both like wound up our legs
to try to get to the ball quicker we
both kicked at the same time and both of
us hit on either side of the ball
it was such a collision
i i actually thought my ankle was going
to break instead the shock of like both
of us hitting the ball
i like flipped over the ball
i also heard this crack really loud the
other guy broke his ankle
uh due to the force and like had to be
carried off the field and all that i
don't even remember who it was i was i
was telling my wife about this the other
day because we've been watching ted
lasso and thinking about soccer and
stuff like that
and then you know so i i didn't you know
play on the team and then when i was in
the army i was in germany and i you know
i enjoyed kicking the soccer ball around
we had our lieutenant try to organize a
team but not too many of the people were
interested in it and quite frankly i
didn't want to play with him after our
first practice together so i didn't do
that and then the last time i really did
anything with soccer was my freshman
year of college
i knew that i knew the guy who was
coaching the soccer team because he was
dating
the
french woman who lived in our foreign
language suite they knew that i spoke
french so they threw me into this french
house her name was cecile rivolti so and
his name was rob howe and so he hung
around a lot and he found out that i
liked playing soccer so he's like why
don't you come join us
and so i did and then he was like oh
[ __ ] why don't you become one of the
trainers and i was like
okay that that sounds fun um
and i i came down here to milwaukee a
couple times to play indoor soccer games
with them
and uh i never i never end up like
playing on the team i would just
practice with the team and
and uh he tried to get me on it but i
was i was kind of busy at the time you
know i i liked partying i liked uh
dating i liked
doing doing my other kinds of exercise
and you know uh that that's our
books as well right so it didn't work
out but man did i have a lot of fun with
those guys probably half the soccer team
was foreign students and i enjoyed that
as well
and since then i you know i appreciate
soccer it's fun to watch i i i can't
really play now because my my knees
being screwed up i'm missing two
ligaments and one knee and the other
one's been compensated for too long so i
would hate to think about what would
happen but you know when i when i had my
kids i tried to get them interested in
it and kicked around the ball but it
didn't really didn't really take that
much
but i've always retained a real love for
the game and i really enjoyed when i did
get to play on teams and so as i
mentioned we've been watching this show
ted lasso about an american coach who
winds up being hired for a british
soccer team and watching all the stuff
has brought back
many of these memories for me and so
you know i thought maybe i would tell
the story and some people would find it
interesting or funny or enjoyable and
that's that's it you know i
i would love to be able to still play
soccer uh because i remember how much it
was how much fun it was
but um i think i'll probably be stuck
just watching from this point on
you